We've looked at templates,
the visual side of an application.
And modules, a container that houses and
encapsulates the different
components of an application.
Now it's time to add in controllers.
This is where we really start
to see Angular coming together.
But first time to play
with some more toys.
Every Lego model can
be put on display but
not all of them actually do anything.
This LEGO car has wheels and
it can move.
It's not just for show.
The power of single page apps is
that you can interact with them.
Angular controllers gives us
the ability to provide both data and
functionality to an app's templates.
Let's add some data to our apps.
We can use Yoman to
generate the files we need.
Let's make the controller first.
We need the yo
angular:controller command.
And let's create
a controller named menu.
This creates a menu file in
the controllers directory.
It also updates the index file
to include this new controller.
While we're setting up our app,
I want this project to
start with a clean slate.
Let's remove this default main file
here, in the controller folder.
And in the view folder.
Now in our new menu controller let's
delete the functions default content.
A controller just like the other
components in angular lives
inside of a module.
The modules already been created.
So we get it and
add the controller to it.
To actually create a controller
use angular's controller method.
The name of the controller comes
first and then the function.
A controller is a constructor function.
Properties of the constructed object
can be used as variables in templates.
let's add properties for
an ID, a name, an image,
and a rating and i'll use these values.
We've added properties to the controller
and the controller to the module.
So Angular knows about our controller,
how to create it and
the data to use when creating it.
Let's add this controller
to the template, but
first we actually need a template.
Let's run yo angular view menu
to generate an HTML template
with the name menu.
The generator creates our
template in the view's directory.
Now that we have our template
we can add it to the page.
This line is left over from
the main file we deleted.
Let's update it to use our menu files.
We can swap out main here for menu and
main controller we can replace
with menu controller as menu.
Just like we use that strange ng app
attribute called a directive to add
a module to the page.
We need to use this directive
to include our new template.
The directive to load the controller is,
ng dash controller.
Then we pass it the name of
the controller we want, menu controller.
And the variable name to use for
instantiation.
Menu.
I promise we'll look at
directives very soon.
Refreshing the page shows
us the templates contents.
Not very exciting, right, let's update
the template to include our data.
Here's what the generator gives
us by default for our template.
And here's the structure I want.
With the HTML structure set,
we need to add in the dynamic content.
Remember that dynamic content
needs to go inside an expression.
For the heading we want
the menu item's name.
So that's menu.name.
Remember, menu here comes from
the ng-controller attribute
which creates an instance of
the controller and names it menu.
Adding the rest of the information
gives us this final template.
On a side note, we're not adding the
items image with an image tag just yet.
We'll fix this in a bit.
And here's our app.
Notice that our templates receiving
its data from the controller, and
everything's displaying correctly.
Awesome.
What do you think about
what we've learned so far?
You now should have a good understanding
that a controller provides
the initial state for a template.
And how to use expressions
to display that information.